rob gronkowski's decision came out of
nowhere yesterday even though we were
watching and waiting and we knew there
was a chance he was going to retire from
your perspective when did you know that
he was calling it quits i thought he was
going to come back uh i really thought
he was going to come back i remember
talking to the patriots and telling him
i'm pretty sure he's coming back wow
that was just my that was just my guess
because
you know i rob loves to play the game
you know and he finished the season so
strong and he was healthy
at the end of the year he got a quad
injury in the super bowl but he was
relatively healthy and it was great to
see him get back to playing that way so
i thought he would come back
but as the time went by and you know i'm
talking to the patriots and they're
wanting to know what he was going to do
and i i called rob this week i said rob
i think it you know i'm not trying to
pressure you but i think it would be
great
to let them know right so they can plan
right accordingly because you'd be a big
loss
and rob's response at that time was very
lukewarm
it wasn't like uh you know i'm leaning
one way or the other so that's when i
had a feeling and but it wasn't until he
called me yesterday
and it's one of those phone calls you
never forget you know i'm on the phone
and i'm i'm dreading it as he's telling
me because
it's so much fun to see him play sure
you know uh just the the fan forget the
agent and
just so much fun being involved with
going to the games and being a part of
his career i'm gonna miss that yeah
these nine years have been extraordinary
with him there's only one rob gronkowski
so i was clinging to that so i was like
rob are you sure
is there anything i can do can i call
the team can i talk to them about you
taking the offseason off maybe taking it
easy on you in training camp yeah right
pitch count something like that you know
right he said nah drew this is it yeah
you know i've really i've thought it
through and i've i'm ready for something
else i've had enough of football
ultimately do you think it was just his
body being beaten to hell that said
enough is enough i think so yeah i think
last year what people don't realize is
rob played with an achilles injury right
he had a calf injury he had a quad
he had a bulging disc he's had three
back surgeries he had a bulging disc i
was worried that would lead to a fourth
surgery and for a lot of the season he
wasn't himself and i i think rob is
accustomed at playing at such a
extraordinary level
i i don't think it was very comfortable
for him to play
at a level that wasn't up to his
standards sure and so i think that was
tough did you have any discussions drew
with the patriots about some sort of a
reduced load a pitch count less practice
time save him for the post season
because he was he was the old gronk
again in the playoffs i did yeah and the
team was very open to the concept of
working with him right and we got
together with coach belichick last
off-season to try and adjust some things
to make it work for rob
uh because rob considered walking away
this time last year well that's i was
gonna how close was it last year to uh
calling to quit pretty close yeah it was
pretty close i think they were saying
last year he would have returned well
said that's a good point it was at this
time last year i was meeting with the
team
um about rob coming back and and he
decided to come and do it he went and he
met with uh coach belichick
right before the draft and made the
commitment that he was coming back and i
think you're right mike winning the
championship because he said that to me
yesterday so you know drew i won another
championship it's three
the time's right you know and he doesn't
have any set plans there there's going
to be a lot of opportunities for him
whether it's a studio host whether it's
a sideline guy uh allah anthony suragusa
what he used to do fun stuff um the
terminator that's what we're calling it
right we went
up all the lines from the original
terminal it's only 17 lines he doesn't
have to deliver much they do a reboot of
the original terminator all he has to
say is i'll be back and off we go you
know what that would be awesome i i
could see him doing a lot of things
he'll be very successful he'll
you know he walked away from 10 million
dollars yeah you know he walked away
from 10 million the patriots obviously
wanted him back you know that was never
a question
i'm just glad that he was in that
position you know what a credit to him a
lot of guys that i have
they play forever because they you know
they can't afford to walk away from that
right thank god rob has so many options
that he can yeah
does he still have all of his football
money banked he does it's a true story
you know you
me yeah
you've met my wife she's got expensive
taste
yeah and then i get double taxed by my
wife no
he hasn't been married he doesn't have
any kids and
he's lived within his means he really
has you know i think he's had the same
vehicle he's never been an extravagant
guy not with jewelry clothing you know
he's really live within his means i got
to give his parents a lot of credit he's
got older brothers that looked out for
him too so i got to ask you this
question just because like i stated
earlier you're so loved by your clients
and you've had some real personalities
okay so whether it was warren sapp who i
got to experience in person uh
who who is who was the craziest
personality of all where you just look
back back at it and go oh my gosh that
was fun a handful all of it shocky was
right at the time shocking very shocking
was definitely one but it had you'd have
to give it to rob yeah you give us a rob
rob was definitely the the
the most entertaining guy i mean just a
breath of fresh air always in a great
mood always funny
even when times were tough coming up
most people don't realize all the
adversity that rob went through i mean
he had an acl yeah
bad one where he towards acl and mcl
right he had three surgeries on his back
right throughout his football one in
college one in college he had four on
his forearm that was almost a career
ending
yeah the staff in fact
right yeah
this guy went through a lot
and that's what i'll remember most about
rob the
the joy the great personality but also
the toughness
their perseverance this wasn't a walk in
the park for him i mean he battled what
are we talking about nine surgeries yeah
it's insane you know remarkable and
never got jaded never lost his nature
never lost his love of the game never
always just went that's what amazes me
about football players
they get broken down and they dedicate
themselves to getting back 100 going
back out into that fray knowing they're
going to get broken down again and have
to keep doing it over and over and over
and rob is a blue collar guy he never
complained once about blocking he would
take on defensive ends he would do all
the dirty work he was never a guy that
was just all about he never called me
once and said man i'm not getting any uh
catches they're not throwing the ball to
me never not in his entire career he
would go a whole game a block and he
would never he wouldn't have a different
attitude as long as the team won was he
ever annoyed that you know in the last
few years like tight ends passed them up
in nearly average like saudi because we
used to talk about it like that's it's
crazy
he did get annoyed okay yeah
me more so than half yeah and i mean you
know we did rob's contract after a
second year it was very unique what the
patriots did and he wasn't rob
gronkowski the hall of famer after his
second year but we got a very lucrative
extension but we were always chasing the
next contract because he was the best
player yeah so i think we renegotiated
his deal five times
one year we got the patriots to move
money up every other year we got them to
add incentives
just like last year so it seemed like i
was perpetually renegotiating
rob's contract with the with the
patriots but they were great to work
with i mean
they recognized what a unique player he
was and we were always able to go back
to the table and work stuff out for them
at his peak he was i believe the most
dangerous non-quarterback in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports